do you think it's a good idea for
artists to try to sell their work right
away
in terms of selling your art and and and
jumping in and doing that right away
it's never sad
it's never been satisfying for me for
some reason
just speaking for myself only i think
that um
the things i tend to put the most energy
into
are the passion projects that i either
get paid the least
or nothing once i know i'm getting paid
it's like the job's already done because
i know that the money is coming
if i meet this deadline and i meet this
set of criteria
whether it's x number of words or pages
or whatnot
and i i find it not as fulfilling as the
projects i do for myself
now i can only speak for myself but i do
think that there is something
that can be corrupting to the process
for artists that have success
early in their career it can really be
um almost a hindrance um
as someone who's just uh i mean i've
always struggled between
you know um trying to be responsible
fiscally speaking
and then also doing passion projects
there's that balance where i need to
make
a certain amount of money to be able to
you know
not ever get behind on my bills um
uh but i but i have seen in the past
um friends who become wildly successful
out of the gate
and i think it i think it can hurt them
because that doesn't mean and you see it
you see the phenomenon with
you know filmmakers sophomore efforts or
the you know second album from a band is
always kind of an
off one after a huge success and many
one-hit wonders and one-hit wonders
applies both in music and film
so i do think that there's something
that can be because it creates an
expectation
about well i made x amount of money
doing
x thing it will always be that way
and i can 100 tell you it will not
because the market will change um
what what the market wants out of you
that will change
so um you know their expectations for
you you know you did
um some writing or a piece of music or a
film that was like this
and then the second movie is vastly
different why didn't you do the thing
that we like the first time
when you see filmmakers kind of
consistently putting out
sort of a sameness to their work um that
is
more than likely a fear of deviating
from
from that thing where they're they're
they know they're going to make
a certain amount of money if they
fulfill those requirements and it can be
a hindrance to creativity
so um
so i i don't know i think that i think
that early success
can be an issue um early success or
in my case very little success uh i'll
just say that
like i've done projects and i put things
out in the world
have they been the most financially
successful
no but have i put things out in the
world
that you can see books magazines pieces
of writing
films yes i have done those things and i
have
been able to make a living at it i guess
that may be considered some kind of
success
so i will slightly amend it i'm very
tough on myself
so i i you know
um but i but i do think that money can
be a corrupting a corrupting force
and i think that we see it when we see
people
uh filmmakers we love and usually their
most beloved work if you ask
uh like true filmmaker filmmakers that i
would consider an artist say for example
a david lynch you know i'm pretty sure
he wouldn't say
his big studio films were
and they're very few um we're his most
favorite
but i can't speak for him going back to
what you said earlier sure
and your desire to live a creative life
yeah then you've
been successful with that because you
didn't want to have a nine-to-five job
and you wanted to keep creating whatever
that is whether it's a children's book
whether it's a podcast and you've been
able to do that
and so that's its own success i i guess
yes
i i i never i
yeah yeah you know what i never really
celebrate any success that i've ever had
um but i i consider the success kind of
like just
having a completed project right
um and i have done if you look at the
things i've done
there it is it's a wide range of
different types of things for sure
um so uh
that might seem to be a lack of focus
but
for me it's i will get bored with
something and think well i already know
how to do that
i already know i don't need to make any
more magazines i've done magazines i
want to do
something else you know i want to i'll
do
this podcast type of podcast or i'll do
this
um film project so i'm a fan of doing
things that are different
learning all about it and then moving on
to the next thing
do you think that's a blessing to be
borderline i was watching this miles
davis documentary and he
reinvented himself many many times and
i'm just wondering is that something
that's actually
people would look at it maybe as a
negative but it's actually helped
because you keep doing things you keep
trying new things yeah i keep trying new
things
and i will say that some have succeeded
and some i feel that
miserably um i mean god i did i did a
stand-up comedy album that was
it was kind of terrible but um i tied it
in with like a book
because cds were dying and i'm like well
i'm gonna do a children's book and then
it's also a comedy album whatever
but i did but i got to i got to know
comedians and then i
realized that in order to be successful
in that realm that is a
highly focused thing the people that are
very good at that
the people that i admired people like uh
um
just yoshi obayashi is one of my
favorite i i
we would do stand-up dates together and
wildly
successful he's a comedian that like
other comedians love
and he opens for them so you probably
don't even know who yoshi obayashi is
um but um i'll look him up though
you should yeah look up yoshi obayashi
he's fantastic
he's a korean comedian but has a
japanese sounding name but he
um i learned a lot from him and i just
also learned that in order to do that
that's something where you can
really if you're going to be successful
as a stand-up community that's all you
should do um but i i was
had a lot of people tell me you should
do stand-up this came from
doing television uh for for a while i
did like tv
on and off for like 15 years worked for
a bunch of different shows
and created a couple shows um and
learned what it took but i
but i guess the thing is i get i'll get
bored with something
and once i sort of break it down and
understand it i want to try something
else
so yeah uh
did you do stand up in actual clubs here
in l.a oh yeah coffee store
i did um not comedy store but i did
stamp and i also did
i did like comedy shows um
i did like a show called fanfic theater
we would have comedians
read fanfic that was supposedly taken
from the internet but what they didn't
know is we were actually writing it
um i mean comedians and actors and we
would perform it
um so yeah i just
you know it was sort of an offshoot of
other things that i was doing
um but it was it was fun i mean i got to
know a lot about what myself was my
my limits and i learned what i really
like to do i really like i really like
probably writing more than anything
is probably my most favorite and i also
like to do
crafting as odd as that sound because
something with my hands
whether it's modifying a piece of
furniture or just doing or building
something
i mean i used to work with cars and
motorcycles when i was growing up
and even when i was i rebuilt
a motorcycle 1972 triumph daytona 500
i don't recommend this vehicle by the
way um
the brits aren't known for their
engineering skills i don't think um
i but in any case um i ripped it apart
to the frame and then rebuilt it
and i like that there's something about
that tactile
you know building something i like to
you know
when it comes to filmmaking create a way
of doing something like okay
here's what we have um let's try to do
it like this
you know make a a makeshift
crane out of a two by four you know a
basically a seesaw right like that's a
crane
uh you know or they're just ways of
doing things
um that i think just
you know yes you can pay for this
expensive piece of equipment and an
operator or
you know the way that sam raimi put it
sam raimi
um used this thing that he called the
shaky cam
where he would take a two by four he
would mount a camera to the center of a
of a board and then run with it people
on two
sides and it would give you sort of a
steadicam
feel he used this for his early evil
dead movies
and it was just using what you have i
think it forces you
to think more creatively
and that's why i've always always
admired independent filmmakers is
because
it's all to me about problem solving
which
is my favorite thing to do it's it's
problem solving
is like figuring out a puzzle and
figuring out puzzles is fun
uh i i i do consider myself a gamer
and puzzle games are among my favorites
uh
so so applying that to real life and
creativity
um puzzle solving can be about money it
can be about like
um it just can just run the gamut of
different uh different
ways to solve problems uh i'll give you
an example
um i made this movie called my big fat
independent movie
and there's a character in the movie
that
um it's about two hitmen going to vegas
to pull a botched robbery
it's a parody of a bunch of independent
films inspired by tarantino and
amelie the film homily among others it's
a dumb spoof comedy
i'm not going to sit here and tell you
it's a great film but i
we knew what it was right just trying to
make you laugh
but one of the things is
i had met bob odenkirk on the festival
circuit and i helped
bob get his movie melvin goes to dinner
which is first
what was his first directing effort into
a bunch of film festivals
bob was very grateful uh for me helping
him
and i asked him i said hey can i put you
in my movie i'm making this movie my big
fat independent movie
and i think maybe there's some people
you know in it like padgett brewster or
whatever he said sure i'll be in your
movie
but i've only got 30 minutes and i'm
going to the airport on this day
and in this window of time you can shoot
me
i was like okay all right 30 minutes all
right what do we do
so we wrote this character
of in the trunk of the two hit men
driving to vegas lives this assassin
who's bleeding kind of based on tim
roth's character from reservoir dogs
and every time they would open the trunk
he would be in there and he's like
looking at them saying
i'm thinking about redecorating what do
you think about french doors in here
like it was it was a dumb recurring joke
then we had wild lines of dialogue i
literally
we had bob odenkirk for 30 minutes shot
him out in 30 minutes
and he's in the entire movie so
because you would hear wildlines they'd
be talking to him in the trunk
it was it's ridiculous i know it's
stupid but that was a
um a creative way to solve a problem of
only having an actor for 30 minutes
you're looking at maybe only getting one
line out of them
as it was he was in several scenes
additionally he's
throughout the film as a disembodied
voice in the trunk
it's weird i know but that was that was
a way to solve a problem
take an actor who i love and admire bob
odenkirk
knew him from mr show at the time
but that's just an example a production
example
um and a way to solve that problem and
you saw the rubik's cube
the day it came out no the rubik's cube
is something that is still challenging
to me really but i like surprise
i like puzzles video games i don't know
sparkle unleashed look that one up on
the ps4
okay one day i'll be good at it
you